i mean i feel like the last
year in some chapter really feel like
you've been thriving during the pandemic
bro yeah now the pandemic did it the
pandemic did it because what the
pandemic did it even the playing field
for me
so
whereas like a rapper that's already
booming and doing festivals you could
get all that type of content right every
day your social media looks crazy you
jumping in crowds and um marsh pits and
and you're next to kylie jenner after
parties the pandemic leveled the whole
playing field because now you can't do
that so now you got to compete with me
song for song video for video
bar for bar and i'm gonna i'll do that
you know i mean i'll do you on that so i
feel like that's where i thrived at yeah
i always say like i feel like for
artists who actually can rap the
pandemic
did wonders because everyone's listening
differently they're listening at the
crib they're listening in their airpods
or they were listening driving in their
car as opposed to being at the club
standing on the [ __ ] couch yeah
digesting like microwavable [ __ ]
yeah yeah it took out it took out all
like the the bubble gum [ __ ] for a while
you're thriving freddie gibbs was
thriving right all the griselda's on a
run during the pandemic like i feel like
the bars are like
with the with the [ __ ] that just
happened with the locks kisses at the
height of the rap game it's amazing it's
like so raspberry it feels like naw's
got the number one album on itunes like
i just feel like it's we're kind of like
low-key in like a renaissance of like
dope rap again yeah a lot of the
bullshit's out the window right now